elon musk the boss of the electric car
company tesla says people won't be able
to buy his cars
with digital money anymore it's over
concerns that bitcoin might damage the
environment
but of course the question is how can
digital cash
hurt the environment and is it the
future of money or just a big
unpredictable joke here to explain that
and more is gary stevenson
an ex-city trader turned economist and
commentator gary afternoon to you
hi but how can digital money hurt the
environment
then what's going on okay so the way
that it works is basically
this currency exists only on the
internet the idea behind it is it's
completely independent independent from
the bank of england independent from the
banking system
but it needs to have a way in which it's
created so normal money gets created by
the bank of england how does bitcoin get
created
well it was set up in such a way that
the uh that computers can mine bitcoin
by basically doing a lot of complicated
mathematical operations
that help to maintain the bitcoin system
now originally when bitcoin cost
about 10 what it does now it wasn't
super profitable to mine bitcoin but as
the price has exploded
that means that even if you use a huge
amount of electricity
to do these mathematical computations it
is still profitable
to mine bitcoin what that means is an
enormous number of people have started
mining bitcoin and the electricity
production has blown up so at the moment
bitcoin mining is using more electricity
than the entire country
of argentina and that is people mining
the bitcoin to try to
make new bitcoin and make money
basically just remind us what are
digital currencies then gary let's get
back to basics
yeah so um digital currencies bitcoin
was the first one it basically was born
out of the
2008 financial crisis obviously i'm sure
you'll remember at that time there was a
massive
bailout of the banks um there was a lot
of anger towards the banking system
because of that
and uh this first cryptocurrency bitcoin
was created by an anonymous group
and they stamped on the very first coin
um
we're going to have a bailout of the
banking system something very similar to
this
the idea is basically they wanted to
create a currency that would compete
with the
pounds and pennies in your bank account
and in your wallet the idea being that
people wouldn't need to use the banking
system
wouldn't have to go through the bank of
england and lawyers halifax these banks
that currently control
the money system but actually as you can
see now
12 years later people are not using
these cryptocurrencies
for their usual transactions you can't
use bitcoin to pay your taxes or to
buy a food at tesco but people are
basically using it to speculate
because the price movements have been
enormous uh especially in the last
couple of years they've been
dramatically up it's up about 400
percent this year
it's up about 600 in the last two years
in my opinion it's basically become
a speculative bubble that ordinary
people are looking looking at this and
thinking
well you know i'm stuck at home i can't
work i can't make money in my normal job
maybe i'll just
put everything on bitcoin and i hope it
goes to the moon and i think at the
moment that's what it's become
well if that's the case people must be
pretty annoyed with elon musk
mustn't muslim one tweet and he seems to
have crashed bitcoin's value by about
10 how much damage do you think he's
done gary
well bitcoin's got a lot of form in not
just uh sorry elon musk has got a lot
for me not just a bitcoin market but all
the crypto
markets he's been doing a lot of
tweeting about a lot of cryptos
most notably he's been tweeting about a
currency called dogecoin
which was designed to be a comedy coin
which was
making a joke of how it was worthless
and he tweeted aggressively about it and
it's up i think twenty thousand percent
this year
um elon musk is one of the world's
richest
men um i i have my suspicions that he
knows he can move the market when he
tweets
and he's tweeting to move the market in
his favor
um obviously i don't know exactly what
he's doing he's claiming that it's um
environmental reasons but um he was sued
by the sec um not too long ago for
tweeting and moving the share price of
tesla which is the company he owns
so i think elon musk is a smart guy and
he knows what he's doing he's very
powerful
at moving this market and how smart do
you need to invest
is cryptocurrency for serious investors
or
for just people who want to take a bit
of a punt i mean
anybody can get involved but i think
it's really important to point this out
you know
in the last year or two a lot of people
have encountered really serious
financial difficulties
and other people who a lot of the whom
have really publicized on the internet
have made a lot of money on crypto and
people have made a lot of money
um it's going to be very tempting for a
lot of ordinary people to put a lot of
money in here because they see how much
money other people have made but i think
it's very important that people are
aware that
bitcoin and all other cryptocurrencies
are extremely volatile investments
they're very risky
there's a very real chance they could
fall 70 80 90 percent they have done in
the past so i'd really strongly advise
anybody
don't invest anything in
cryptocurrencies that you cannot afford
to lose
100 of because they are that volatile
they can afford a long way
do you have any yourself gary no i know
i was a money trader for a long time
um i like my money to be able to buy me
things uh
and bitcoin doesn't buy you um well
you'll buy fifty thousand dollars
but you uh you won't be able to buy much
in mcdonald's with it okay
so what do you think you're in the pan
or the future of mummy
i definitely don't think it's the future
of money a lot of people on the internet
think it is the future of money
um look we've had a lot of money
distance in the past we had a gold
monetary system
at the moment we've got a central bank
monetary system the fact is bitcoin is
not backed by anything real
it's not but if it goes to zero you're
not getting anything back for it um the
monetary system we have is backed by the
central bank that promises you it will
be able to
buy you goods and services food pay your
bills
um the gold money system was backed by
gold you could change it for gold
bitcoin is not backed by anything
it is completely unbacked personally in
my opinion i think we're seeing an
enormous speculative bubble and i think
it will fall a long way but um if you
bought it at 5 000 you'd probably be
happy
and i'd be buying it good to talk to you
economist and commentator thanks for
being with us
you